[Music]
school of rock is one of our favorite
jack black movies and it also happens to
be drew barrymore she's hosting a live
watch party of the film for this
weekend's cbs sunday night movie but
we're gonna throw a little pre-party now
okay because only e.t rocked out with
jack behind the scenes
we're the school of rock baby
days it's a magical power
the power of rock something dangerous
and exciting let's go in this smash hit
comedy jack plays a washed-up musician
and inappropriate substitute teacher who
ends up connecting to his students by
forming a rock band
[Music]
the role was specifically written for
black i've got a hangover
who knows what that means doesn't that
mean you're drunk no means i was drunk
yesterday
e.t was on set and saw how jack fit
right in with the young cast
that's him goofing off in between takes
and showing no mercy i want to buy a
book on sticks and just come back and
just destroy every kid in the classroom
crying and check out this 10 year old
little cutie memory
okay good that's icarly star miranda
cosgrove in her first film role a behind
the scenes secret i can sing she can
sing in real life so miranda was given a
lesson on how to sing off-key the role
also inspired her to take up rock
lessons after the movie i booked up
electric guitar lessons which is really
fun as for the band
director richard linklater refused to
take on the film unless all the kids
could play for real
they're really great musicians
they're actually much better than me
their instruments it's actually kind of
embarrassing it's uh
dare i say kick ass